the next time you put something in that
mouth that doesn't belong there i'm
gonna remove it and then call the police
before they were superheroes they were
teenage heartthrobs
ever have a bit of deja vu watching the
mcu movies
any guess which marvel actor played
pretty much themselves in a teen classic
how about the performer who to this day
has never seen the film that shot them
to fame
isn't that carter basin we know him now
as bucky barnes but if he looks familiar
it's because we were probably gawking
over him when we were younger watching
him play carter basin and gossip girl
for the first three seasons
the romanian-american actor actually
dated his co-star leighton meester for a
couple of years while they were filming
what are you doing with this insect
having the time of my life
thank you very much between gossip girl
and the falcon and the winter soldier he
was
plenty busy working and had roles in the
once upon a time series
and in popular movies like the martian
and i tonya
how do we know it's gonna end any
differently than it did before
because before you didn't have me before
she was captain marvel
she was a queen bee when exactly
well at the young age of 14 we saw a
young blonde brie larson as liz in the
teen movie sleepover
she had far less experience back then
but she still pulled it off and gave a
really memorable performance
we totally forgot about this early role
since she looked so
different she also appeared as 6 girl in
the classic film 13 going on 30.
my spirit animal was a frog he is one of
the most recognizable stars in hollywood
now and his performance as peter quill
is always brilliant
but before he joined the mcu he played
in loads of successful projects
one of his earliest standout roles was
playing che the hippie who introduced
summer to activism in the oc
his projects and roles are quite varied
from the sitcom parks and rec to
jurassic park and of course
guardians of the galaxy that is the
coolest sentence i've ever heard
somebody talk
before he became a marvel mvp gunn was a
regular in stars hollow
it's actually where he got his big break
the classic gilmore girls
while we all remember his brilliant
performance as kirk gleason the town
oddball
he actually had three different roles in
the show his first appearance came in
the second episode of the series where
he played the small role
of a dsl installer i was told that you
wouldn't be here but to look for a
ceramic frog with a key in it i don't
understand
we can't find the frog fast forward to
the third episode where he appeared as
swan man
until finally episode 5 brought us kirk
the dsl installer role was actually the
reason he was considered for the bigger
role at all
that was the first part he auditioned
for and when he had the casting
directors thought there was something
special about him so they rehired him to
take on a bigger role
i'm the new assistant manager here they
kept writing him in and
made him a series regular and one of the
most beloved characters on the show
just goes to show there really are no
small roles
before she was gwen stacy in the amazing
spider-man and its sequel
she was a part of a very definitive film
for a generation
that's right we're talking about easy a
it's incredible it's phenomenal it's
pretty much a perfect movie
her performance as all of pendergast
stole our hearts and shot her right to
fame
for such a major role it's pretty
surprising to know that the actress has
actually
never seen the iconic movie herself part
of the reason for this is that when she
was filming she was just 20 years old
and felt a lot of pressure to be good
she found herself quite overwhelmed by
the amount of responsibility and weight
she carried in the movie that the whole
experience wasn't so enjoyable
while she did attend a friends and
family screening she actually snuck out
after just a couple scenes and has still
never seen the full movie i found it
really challenging emotionally
the deadpool actor's career has been
extensive but one of our favorite
reynolds throwbacks is definitely the
classic romcom just
friends wow you don't see that every day
he'd been building his career for a
while but this movie was when he really
began to blow up
his makeup to create his 12-pound
unrecognizable face took a whole
four hours to apply each time he had to
perform as his uncool high school self
we have fun we work hard and we win
national championships
she rocked as mj but her star turn as
torrent shipment and bring it on is a
definite career highlight surprisingly
she wasn't even the first pick for the
role
once she was finally offered the role
she actually turned it down a few times
before accepting
thank goodness she finally did say yes
because it's hard to imagine anyone
else playing that role
[Music]
plus it wound up being her big break
into the industry dunsta said that
torrance was the character she played
that she felt the closest to
she was a 16 year old real life
cheerleader so
yeah she was basically torrance
who's speaking it's your conscience
we don't talk a lot these days remember
when ant-man of the mcu is playing a
teenager in clueless
how about this k.u hat he wore in the
film that was a special piece that
actually belonged to the actor himself
he got to pay tribute to his alma mater
wearing it but unfortunately he's never
seen it since wrapping the film
can you imagine the nerve of that guy we
obviously love her as she venom in the
mcu
but remember her time on dawson's creek
as jen lindley
she was actually really insecure about
her time on the show because even though
she was one of the four leads she was so
often overshadowed especially by katie
holmes's character
it makes me um timid
she noticed how much less screen time
she was getting and was constantly
worried that she was doing something
wrong
she also wasn't a fan of her character's
passing at the end of the series
we're on michelle's side for this one we
wanted more jen
my name is holly holliday what's yours
remember when the pepper potts actress
was singing and dancing as the
substitute teacher holly holliday and
glee
that was actually her first television
role and all thanks to her friend ryan
murphy who wrote the part into the
series for her
it was a pretty memorable experience for
her considering that's where she met her
husband brad falchuk
one of the other co-creators of the
series not to mention she won an emmy
for the role
not bad now might be a really good time
for you to get angry
i'm always angry the hulk actor gave one
of his most charming performances as the
always ready with razzle's best friend
in 13 going on 30.
however this performance almost didn't
happen at all
ruffalo almost dropped out of the movie
when having learned choreography for
that classic thriller scene
he was so overwhelmed and hated the
rehearsal process
it probably didn't help that jennifer
garner had experience as a ballet dancer
though i think it's a in a weird way a
really wholesome movie for
for for young women does this ballerina
look familiar
maybe if she looked a bit greener yes
that is marvel's gamora
aka zoe saldana the actress played ava
rodriguez in the cult classic film
center stage and was actually one of the
only non-dancers in the film
that was the best time i ever had in my
life
she was only 20 years old and really
made her mark on the scene
many apologies you may just do she's
rocked the big screen as valkyrie but
remember her television debut
she played jackie cook and veronica mars
this role was one that really prepared
her for all the surprising and dynamic
female characters she would get to play
later in her career
it's a dubious talent but snagging guys
has always been a breeze
thompson has said that it's definitely
one of the most treasured roles from her
past
before he had spidey senses he was a
genius who helped to create facebook in
the film the social network
yes that's him playing mark zuckerberg's
friend eduardo saverin
it was a very special shoot director
david fincher
actually had garfield whispering insults
to jesse eisenberg between takes to help
put eisenberg in the right headspace
the jerk who betrayed his friend i am
aware of the effect i have on women
we totally forgot that idris alba made
an appearance as charles minor on the
mockumentary series for six episodes
playing michael scott's boss
his list of credits is long but his time
on the office was definitely the first
project he did in that type of style
which is pretty much the polar opposite
of his experience with the mcu
it's not for everybody i suppose the
nostalgia
is real it's no surprise so many of
these loved actors were parts of movies
and tv shows that were so formative for
us growing up
now we're just prepping to go back and
re-watch as many of these as we can now
while we wait for the next mcu movie